ein ring wie eine skulptur mit antilopen
kopf
ein kettenanhänger als tätowierter hand
mit koi
die finger geschmückt mit saphir und
diamanten details die oft erst auf den
zweiten blick auf heim
die kreationen des karlsruher
goldschmieds otto jakob sind voller
humor und andeutungen
wie dieser uhr schmuck den er reiche
schwarzen schönheit jetzt für mich
interessanter weise bei einem
schmuckstück dann vorhanden
wenn es eine vibration hat und die
vibration ist oft durch eine störung die
sogar noch mit drin ist das heißt das
schlimmste ist wenn es so glatt
gebürstet schönes auto jacob ist
autodidakt das handwerk hat sich der
goldschmied setzt beigebracht er
orientierte sich dabei an der
schmiedekunst der alten etruskern und
kelten kulturen die ihn schon als kind
faszinierten zehn mitarbeiter setzen
gemeinsam mit ihm seine entwürfe um sie
verarbeiten auch unkonventionelle
materialien wie ebenholz oder tropische
samen müssen sie mit gold und
edelsteinen
ich hätte wahrscheinlich keine so eine
vielfalt wenn ich nicht alle möglichen
lieblingsmaterialien hätte es ist so ich
hab mir sehnsucht nach einem bestimmten
material dann arbeite ich mit dem dann
ist das irgendwann flug und dann habe
ich als gegenpol oft das bedürfnis mit
einem andersartigen material zu erhalten
bevor die 64-jährige sich den schmuck
widmete studierte er bei georg baselitz
malerei doch die erfüllt die nicht und
er begann seine kreativen fantasien in
schmuck umzusetzen
für georg baselitz entwarf der
goldschmied diese anstecknadel baselitz
wurde sein erster zahlen der kunde
weitere aufträge folgten wie von dem
künstler jörg immendorff
er malte für den juwelier sogar ein bild
darauf zu sehen im dorf auf dem turm zu
babel die goldene hand soll auto jacob
symbolisieren dass ich mit diesen
künstlern zum teil dann nicht nur zu tun
hatte sondern dass die begannen meine
sachen zu wollen und dass ich dann quasi
die ehre hatte für die zu arbeiten und
natürlich eine hohe stimulation das für
mich war denn nicht irgendein
durchschnitts werk zu fabrizieren
sondern in etwas bedeutendes zu machen
und das war man kann sagen der anfang
meiner arbeit
inzwischen ist er seit mehr als 20
jahren sehr erfolgreich weltweit otto
jakob schmuckstücke sind kleine
kunstwerke
sie erzählen geschichten oft mit einer
starken symbolik sie sind auch
kostbarkeiten die schon mal eine viertel
million euro kosten können schlimmste
ist das ist dieser etwas abwehr in der
begriff von dekoration die eigentlich
nur noch eine hülle es in der nicht
hinter der nichts mehr enthalten ist
das heißt ich will immer inhalte
schaffen
die mein leben bereichern
viele von otto jacobs arbeiten sind
inspiriert von der natur
in ihr sucht er nach aussagekräftigen
formen die zu schmuck werden können
so entstehen zum beispiel ohrringe in
form von blättern oder kiefern
ich hab mich in die welt gestellt und
habe mit ihnen gehabt seitdem ich diese
dinge eben machen und es ist einfach nur
das notwendige dass ich arbeiten mit
dieser selbstverständlichkeit führt otto
jakob auch zukünftig weiter zu kreieren
ausdrucksstark und immer auch ein
bisschen fantastisch